c'est l'aboutissement de plus de trente
ans de travail la digue de montesson est
devenu réalité pour la commune un
dossier initié par l'ancien maire de la
commune de 1995 à 2020 jean françois
bayle on a beaucoup souffert pour la
voir maintenant on peut dire que tout
est réellement bouclé et que cette
population du quartier de la borde et
maintenant à l'abri des crues les plus
importantes quelques 1500 habitants
vivent dans ce quartier ils seront
dorénavant protégé une nécessité pour la
commune avec une adaptation du projet en
fonction de l'évolution de la
législation sur la protection de la
biodiversité
lorsqu'on retient le fleuve par le biais
d'une digue on doit le court penser en
ouvrant
des terrains de manière à ce que le le
fleuve puisse reprendre sa place et
redonner au fleuve ce qu'il a ce qu'on
lui a pris aujourd'hui avec moi à la
fois ce bel ouvrage on a aussi une belle
zone de biodiversité
au total 14 millions d'euros ont été
investis pour ce projet plusieurs
participations de l'état du conseil
départemental de la région à travers des
fonds européens ou encore de la
communauté d'agglomération saint germain
boucles de seine la compétence de lutte
contre les risques d'inondation est
devenue intercommunale et donc on a mis
en place un système un plan de
financement avec la région du
département de l'état de l'agencé de
l'eau
des villes et de l'interco pour arriver
enfin à lancer cette opération au total
ce projet a permis de prolonger la dic
sur 780 mètres avec une hauteur d'un
mètre 20 par rapport au niveau de la
route en prenant comme référence la crue
de 1955